pudding I'm making one of my absolute
favorite Italian desserts panna cotta
with that quintessential Italian
flavoring expresser
start by immersing two leaves of
gelatine in cold water and leave to soak
into a small saucepan at Karthus sugar
cream milk sugar and a shot-up good
strong coffee
gently bring to a simmer and remove from
the hob
squeeze out the soap gelatine leaves and
stir into the hot cream until completely
dissolved
pour your cream mixture into a jug and
fill your molds just shorter the rim
rinsing your molds in cold water before
filling will make it easier to get your
panna cotta out once it's set
leaving the fridge for at least two to
three hours or overnight
to make your cinnamon hazelnut brittle
pour castor sugar into a pan and cook
over medium heat until the sugar melts
to a deep golden-brown
scattered toasted hazelnuts into the
caramel dust with ground cinnamon and
leave to set at room temperature
when your panna cotta is firm giving
each mold a quick dip into boiling water
should ensure a perfect stress-free exit
onto the plate
dressed with a shot of crunchy hazelnut
brittle nothing could be so deliciously
elegant